hard-pressed firefighters in the West
are getting reinforcements from some
unlikely places they've pulled in crews
from across the country to battle deadly
Inferno 'he's like the car fire in
Northern California but one unique crew
fighting that wildfire traveled
thousands of miles across the Pacific
they are American nationals from Samoa a
tropical US territory about 2,500 miles
south of Hawaii via via rail shows is
how their most powerful tool may not be
a shovel or chainsaw but the harmonics
sound of their voices these are the all
too common sounds familiar to anyone
caught up in one of nature's most
powerful acts of destruction far more
unusual is what takes their place when
they finally subside a choir of strong
steady voices echoing through the
Cathedral of a burnt-out forest a sound
rarely if ever heard anywhere in the
Northern Hemisphere everyone always ask
where is American song woman and we're
like that's just a little dot on the
equator the National Park Service's
Samoa 61 fire crew 17 guys from that
little dot on the equator we're here for
a purpose you know we want to help any
way burski is one of the team's vets for
the past five summers he's made the
almost 5,000 mile journey north along
with a group he calls his brothers we
try and bring back our culture our
father more we try and stay positive
what a lot of people tell us is that
they've never seen a fire team so
positive that positivity comes through
music without warning they break into
song just about everywhere from the mess
tent
[Music]
to the dusty old school bus they ride
into the fire zone each morning each day
ends back at camp with the same
inspirational anthem it's a church song
and it's just something that's part of
our culture our belief in God is very
strong
the team can earn almost half a year's
salary during a month on the fire lines
with all this grueling back-breaking
work it's not the main reason they do it
they feel like they're helping America
ney Konya coordinates the movements of
federal fire crews like the Samoans they
feel like they're part of this country
right now and these guys have so much
energy that people just want to be part
of it you guys are happy yeah how can
you be happy doing some of those I don't
know it's just the way we're raised back
home and in a region that suffered so
much loss that infectious energy is a
welcome import from a spiritual culture
on the other end of the world receive es
this morning Matteo Gallo read in
California raising voices and raising
spirits love that spirit yeah